[Musique]
Mazarine Mitterrand un jour on dit
volontiers que la France est un paradis
peuplé de gens qui se croit en enfer
est-ce que c'est un constat que vous
partagez
chasse d'accord avec cette phrase alors
c'est peut-être un peu excessif mais en
même temps c'est c'est un mot assez
assez charmant il y a très drôle
c'est d'abord un paradis ça c'est
évident un paradis à tous égards
géographie avec une histoire foisonnante
et passionnante alors est-ce que les
Français se plaignent toujours oui il y
a une petite tendance à se fin mais
c'est tellement agréable en même temps
de la République
un esprit critique très affûté et
lorsque la critique devient plus assez
simple que constructrice ou constructive
c'est voilà il y a peut-être l'aspect un
petit peu bougon qui ressort mais en
même temps l'esprit critique c'est
important aussi alors on dit que ce pays
justement il se plaint sans arrêt et
tout est-ce qu'il est fragmenté ce pays
tel que vous voyez aujourd'hui parce que
on dit bon il y a des jeunes contre les
vieux il y a les campagnes contre les
villes
les élites contre le peuple ou le peuple
contre les élites il y a
l'apparition du communautarisme aussi
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que oui je pense
qu'il y a une certaine fragmentation
mais qui n'est pas nécessairement un
fait français enfin c'est quelque chose
d'assez mondial déjà du fait des réseaux
sociaux qui qui par leur forme même la
fragmentation créer des bulles et puis
voilà l'algorithme lui-même fait que de
toute façon on va aller de plus en plus
vers des archipels qui n'arriveront plus
à dialoguer les uns avec les autres
ensuite je serai peut-être moins
sévère sur sur certaines types de de
rupture par exemple générationnelle je
crois pas enfin je comprends pas tout à
fait celle qui me paraît la plus en
effet la plus inquiétante aujourd'hui
c'est plus celle qui
qui opposerait et les résultats des
élections
m'ont montré qui opposeraient les
classes populaires et ce qu'on appelle
les élites alors j'aime pas trop
employer terminologie parce que d'emblée
elle s'inscrit un petit peu dans une
tradition populiste mais de fait il y a
quand même une sorte de je sais pas
c'est une fracture mais en tout cas un
aveuglement réciproque et non
communication entre alors des élites
entre guillemets ou les tenant lieu
d'une certaine pseudo-science politique
ou d'une science économique il
s'agissait d'une science et je ne pense
pas qu'il s'agit d'une science et de
l'autre côté des gens qu'on n'entend pas
qui ont effectivement invisibles alors
qu'ils le sont de moins en moins parce
que ils manifestent leur colère et moi
je vois dans cette fracture quelque
chose qui est très grave à mes yeux en
tout cas qui est
à l'absence de la gauche quoi il y a une
forme de démission de la gauche qui a
complètement oublié ses classes
populaires alors vous pensez que le
cette fracture cette fracture non cette
opposition droit de gauche elle a
disparu
elle a disparu je pense qu'elle va se
remettre d'une autre c'est pas définitif
c'est pas définitif mais en revanche et
c'est comme s'il y avait eu une sorte de
comment dire de rencontre justement
entre deux types de fractures qui est
d'un côté la fracture classe populaire
et
élite allez utilisons ce terme par
facilité et de l'autre côté également
une forme de fracture alors presque
culturelle à l'intérieur de la gauche
entre une gauche métropolitaine on va
dire d'une bourgeoisie éclairée qui
effectivement
[Musique]
va se battre pour l'extension des droits
subjectifs on va dire et de l'autre côté
tout ce qui est de l'ordre des droits
individuels un combat tout à fait noble
et juste mais qui peut pas oublier de
l'autre côté que ben il y a des combats
sociaux qui sont prédominants et
peut-être qui devraient primer en tout
cas à chronologiquement sur les combats
sociétaux enfin on retrouve cette
fracture entre le social et le sociétal
et je pense qu'on a un petit peu oublié
se poser la question on va s'occuper de
la droite après mais la gauche ça
m'intéresse parce que ça veut dire que
la gauche a perdu le peuple en fait un
petit peu
peut-être de minorité c'est ce qu'on dit
pas mal c'est que s'occupe d'abord elle
vit un peu entre soi effectivement dans
la gauche comme la droite c'est à dire
que là aussi on retrouve une forme de
fracture qui est presque géographique
pour le coup qui est la fracture entre
les les villes et la ruralité et c'est
vrai que cette fracture à l'incarne en
quelque sorte physiquement
une forme d'éloignement qui aurait entre
je sais pas les têtes ponçantes d'une
enfin j'allais dire d'une gauche mais
d'une droite également et de l'autre
côté des gens qui auraient été exclus de
la politique du fait que c'est pas une
maîtriserait pas la pensée économique en
vigueur et c'est vrai qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est qui est compliqué à
comprendre dès lors que la politique
c'est de plus en plus
comment dire inscrit dans une forme de
croyance scientifique dans l'idée que il
y aurait des choses à savoir dans une
forme de technocratie quoi globalement
et donc ça coupe quelque chose ça coupe
l'idée même de la participation des uns
et des autres au fait politique offert
de la politique c'est pas nécessairement
avoir fait l'ENA quoi et ça ça pose un
problème alors il y a un mot que vous
avez utilisé tout à l'heure qui
s'appelle le populisme
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète ça
se populisme dont on sait pas trop
d'ailleurs s'il est de droite ou de
gauche il peut être des deux le général
Boulanger était plutôt de gauche et il
avait
pas mal de nationalistes de droite avec
lui est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
vous fait peur ça justement on l'a vu
d'une certaine façon avec les gilets
jaunes qui n'avaient pas de leader qui
n'avait pas de chef et dont les
revendications étaient pour le moins
épars il y avait pas de de mot d'ordre
qui réunissait tout le monde finalement
il y avait de la colère il y avait de la
colère qui n'a pas su transformer
précisément en revendications politiques
mais le problème c'est de ne pas avoir
entendu cette colère c'est ça qui est
grave évidemment que la colère ne se
suffit pas évidemment que la colère peut
donner lieu à des formes de d'engagement
extrême et de violence également mais si
cette colère n'est pas entendue que veut
dire diriger un peuple que veut dire
faire de la politique sage enfin
vraiment je ne sais pas quoi et donc
bien sûr que la colère ne suffit pas et
bien sûr qu'il faut qu'elle se
transforme et bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'elle soit réfléchie et
objectiver dans des propositions très
concrètes mais
à couper l'une de l'autre c'est à dire
la racine même du fait politique qui est
un désir de vivre et de l'autre côté une
forme de sciences qui n'est plus
entendue enfin voilà qui n'est plus
comprise et surtout qui ne prend pas en
compte la réalité de la vie des gens je
pense que effectivement c'est la porte
ouverte ou populisme alors le populisme
ce qui me fait peur je je sais pas le
populisme c'est pas que négatif même si
bien que d'ailleurs c'est Pierre André
ta guère
devenu au populisme cette mésaventure
que c'était devenu un mot très à la mode
et positif mais historiquement
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément que
négatif néanmoins évidemment on sait les
dérives possible du populisme et le fait
qu'un leader
manipuler les foules le problème c'est
quand le peuple devient la foule quand
le peuple devient la masse et là
effectivement c'est un peu ça
extrêmement dangereux c'est ça si on
l'entend pas mais si on l'entend alors
le peuple se reconstitue en tant que
peuple on est un pays conservateur on
est un pays révolutionnaire
les deux
on est plutôt un pays de droite si on
regarde statistiquement les mêmes sur la
Cinquième République les présidents élus
y compris à gauche puisqu'il y a eu des
cohabitations
plutôt donc un pays conservateur ou on
reste sur ses acquis en même temps on
est incessamment travaillé par un désir
Ré
que vous connaissez bien évidemment
regardez je me fais un effet de la
France une certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose de très grande de très
particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle il faut que la France joue
son rôle c'est exact et pour qu'elle
joue son rôle il faut qu'elle soit la
France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin alors évidemment
c'est général de Gaulle on est en 1965
on est au mois de décembre on est entre
les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle de la première au
suffrage universel direct et contre
toute attente et bien le général de
Gaulle est mise en ballotage par
quelqu'un que vous connaissez très très
bien c'est la première fois qu'il se
prête à un exercice qui est l'interview
on dit qu'elle vient de loin elle vient
de nous pour vous la France
[Musique]
difficile à signer des origines pour un
pays comme pour un peuple comme pour un
individu on est quand même fait de
métissage et heureusement c'est ça qui
est la richesse d'une nation alors elle
vient d'où on peut avoir une réponse
historique moi je suis pas historienne
mais il faut avoir une réponse
historique mais qu'est-ce que ça nous
raconte on pourrait avoir une réponse
politique voir philosophique elle vient
elle vient des idées peut-être qui l'ont
faites et qui ont fait son rayonnement
international elle vient de la
Révolution française elle vient la
Révolution française qui est elle-même
vient de l'Ancien Régime donc tout
phrase de Marc bloc évidemment dans les
transferts quand il dit qu'il y a deux
catégories de Français qui ne
comprendront jamais l'histoire de France
ceux qui refuse de vibrer au souvenir du
sacre de Reims ce qui dit sans émotion
le récit de la fête de la Fédération
vous êtes d'accord avec ça exactement
bien sûr il faut prendre en charge cette
richesse et cette complexité et cette
ambivalence enfin toute l'histoire est
faite cette complexité mais c'est vrai
que en France elle est elle est
particulièrement visible et radicale
parce que voilà il y a eu une révolution
française qui ou qui a rayonné pas
seulement dans son préhistorique mais
surtout dans son bois symbolique mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez unique pour
le coup vous êtes d'accord avec la
phrase de Ronan quand il dit que c'est
un plébiscite de tous les jours la
France
on en a beaucoup parlé quand il s'était
dit du débat sur l'identité française on
est allé chercher Ronan en disant mais
le Français ça veut dire que tous les
matins on se réveillant on se dit que ce
que je peux faire pour ce pays et je
suis pour ce pays quoi c'est un peu ça
non je me méfie toujours du thermidité
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
l'identité française
l'identité et à penser que l'identité
est faite d'une multiplicité bien sûr
mais dans ce cas-là bon bah ça veut tout
y a rien dire quoi
ensuite bien sûr que ça veut dire
quelque chose néanmoins de se sentir
français
c'est pas au sens Chauvin du terme ni
nationaliste parce que les dérives sont
faciles aussi dans ce sens-là le
nationalisme après tout a été l'un des
ferments identitaires de la France et
des Français je pense pas qu'il faillit
souscrire parce que je ne pense que
c'est encore plus dangereux que le
populisme c'est pas du tout antagoniste
et donc se sentir français
parce qu'on appartient à un pays à des
frontières peut-être à une culture
je pense que c'est dangereux même si
c'est une définition qui court
aujourd'hui l'idée de l'appartenance
culturel on voit bien comment ce
discours est brandi à l'extrême droite
l'identité d'un peuple français qui
serait son identité précisément
historique culturelle mon dès lors qu'on
pense l'unité d'un peuple on s'égare en
tout cas on prend des risques parce que
ça veut rien dire l'unité d'un peuple
par définition et d'autant plus
lorsqu'on vit en démocratie or la France
est quand même une démocratie et c'est
fondateur aussi de son esprit on vit
dans la conflictualité et donc si on est
dans la conflictualité c'est ça devient
difficile de penser l'unité alors
ensuite qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
français bon c'est vous prenez toute son
histoire quand même vous n'êtes pas
comme le courant aujourd'hui un courant
qui nous vient des États-Unis d'ailleurs
mais qui a été inspiré par des
philosophes français philosophe français
relu et construire
qu'elle soit exactement
Foucault
mais donc il consiste à effacer des
périodes
détestables on va dire de notre histoire
ou que certains contestent ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens sinon un sens militant
moi je suis pas évidemment dans cette
dans ce combat là mais parce que je sais
pas trop ce qui vaut peut-être
d'ailleurs à la gauche enfin pardon je
vous interrompre
[Musique]
j'entends j'entends ce qui ce qui
revendiquait derrière c'est à dire que
bon il y a cette idée que
on peut pas
célébrer des anciens esclavagistes mais
ensuite ça dépend à quel endroit on se
passe si on se place à un endroit de la
militance les choses peuvent se
comprendre si on se place d'un point de
vue historique c'est absurde évidemment
absurde vous avez signé une pétition il
y a pas très longtemps il y a pas très
longtemps il y a 2 ans je crois sur une
certaine forme de féminisme qui vous
déplaisait et qui disait en gros votre
propos c'était de dire
la gauche morale elle s'égare finalement
il faut revenir au fondamentaux de de la
lutte justement pour des droits et tout
ça et c'est donc cette moralisme c'est
ça que vous condamnez en fait d'une
certaine façon de la gauche en général
j'aime pas trop qu'on donne des leçons
de morale et c'est vrai que la gauche à
cette petite tendance de faire la morale
à tout le monde et je sais pas et
d'avoir mon propre les valeurs morales
le monopole de la morale et je pense
qu'à confondre moral et politique on
fait un
on fait une grande erreur et encore une
fois le résultat des élections en
témoigne à mon avis
on peut pas expliquer aux uns et aux
autres comment il faut penser comment il
faut vivre c'est quoi ce terrorisme
moral et il y a la politique c'est pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec la morale alors
qu'on moralise la vie politique bien
entendu ça c'est très important mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec transformer la
politique en morale sinon on revient à
une forme de de théologie quoi la morale
elle est si quelqu'un la détient en
propre et qu'il prétend je sais pas
qu'il prétend en faire l'unique pensée
je pense que là on rentre dans des
choses extrêmement dangereuse
justement c'est sans doute sans doute
cette moralisme vient des États-Unis
mais néanmoins il y a toujours une
petite tendance de la gauche morale
d'ailleurs on parlait de la Révolution
française tout à l'heure
dès la Révolution française il y avait
quand même une sorte de de mariage
parfois un petit peu forcé entre
général et politique alors c'est vrai
que quelque part y compris les droits de
l'homme ça s'appelle et ça convoque
quelque chose qui serait de l'ordre
d'une morale mais mais c'est pas la
morale au sens normatif du terme c'est
ça reste des droits précisément une
sorte d'idéal vers lequel il faut
atteindre et vers lequel la politique
doit mener mais c'est pas la morale au
sens où un certain nombre de d'hommes et
de femmes politiques nous dirait comment
il faut penser la promesse de notre
devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité vous
trouvez qu'elle est encore
aujourd'hui assurée
assurer elle n'est jamais assez par
définition précisément parce que là
aussi c'est à la fois une devise et un
idéal qui dit idéal dit que le réel est
toujours en deçà mais c'est précisément
parce qu'il y a un écart entre l'idéal
et le réel que la politique a encore du
sens donc bien sûr que la fraternité
n'est pas assez fraternelle bien sûr que
l'égalité n'est jamais assez égale et
que les conditions d'égalité ne sont pas
assez assurées mais
ça reste je trouve un mot d'ordre
magnifique il faudrait y ajouter la
laïcité qui est quand même une
singularité très française là pour le
coup ce qu'il faudrait y ajouter la
laïcité je sais pas bien enfin moi je
suis tout à fait
évidemment laïque et je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention au retour du
religieux
dans le discours politique évidemment
pour autant il faut bien s'entendre sur
ce qu'on entend par laïcité c'est
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de combats
et de débats à l'intérieur même des
promoteurs de la laïcité sur ce qu'il
faut la laïcité dure militante ou est-ce
que la laïcité permet néanmoins
l'expression précisément du sentiment
religieux
et assure l'égalité de cette expression
là dans toutes les religions alors le
président du président oui de Gaulle
premier président de la 5e République il
la France elle a un rôle à jouer dans le
monde rayonnement vous êtes écrivaine
est-ce que la langue la langue française
et plus loin que ça la francophonie
justement est-ce que c'est un outil dont
on se sert suffisamment pour essayer de
promouvoir nos idées et notre
rayonnement non bien sûr pas assez
d'autant plus lorsque c'est l'anglais
qui qui est devenu la langue
internationale et que la Francophonie a
reculé et que il y a intéresse pas
beaucoup je trouve j'ai pas l'impression
que une politique très forte du point de
vue de la Francophonie mais mais bien
sûr que la langue s'il fallait définir
une identité française même si je trouve
l'identité je la trouverai dans la
langue c'est ce que disait Anna arène
exilé aux États-Unis pour qui la langue
reste la langue maternelle reste le pays
quoi le contre un bal partout avec soi
et aujourd'hui ou on est rentré quand
même dans une crise des réfugiés d'exil
cette question de la langue elle est
fondamentale parce que la langue ça
reste quand même l'expression de soi
quoi l'expression de l'intimité et
l'expression des émotions les plus
profondes et c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue là la langue française moi j'y
verrai un petit peu mon lieu mon
assiette voilà mais mes racines et par
rapport alors ça c'est mon rapport
personnel à la langue mais je pense
qu'effectivement
si on voulait promouvoir des valeurs
françaises il faudrait évidemment
promouvoir la culture et la culture
passe essentiellement par la langue
alors d'autant plus pour pour un
écrivain mais c'est vrai que je trouve
malheureusement qu'elle est assez
minorée cette culture française et cette
littérature française
voilà mais c'est parce que en effet
l'anglais est devenu tellement
omniprésent et tellement puissant y
compris dans nos propres universités que
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on est fait les
efforts nécessaires pour que cette
langue justement par une des opérations
de promotion n'est pas au supermarché
mais
d'aide de la part de l'État ou c'est
comment ça comment on fait justement
pour que ça est-ce que par exemple la
France s'occupe suffisamment de la
Francophonie non je pense que très
clairement on est en deçà par rapport
mais la Francophonie qui est une
richesse quand même avec beaucoup de
pays africains beaucoup bien sûr et le
français recule notamment en Afrique et
c'est et je pense qu'on n'est pas du
tout enfin voilà non je pense que le
très clairement la politique française
aujourd'hui
relative à la Francophonie est assez
faible et c'est vraiment enfin c'est ça
pour le coup c'est une perte de
puissance quoi et qu'est-ce que vous
pensez justement aujourd'hui alors ça
dépasse un peu le cadre de la France
mais la France est en première ligne bon
il y a une guerre en Europe en Ukraine
il y a un sentiment antioxydantal quand
même qui est assez violent aujourd'hui
qui est
pas tant en Russie mais on sent que
c'est un peu pareil en Chine pourquoi ça
vous pensez que ça existe cette c'est
cette volonté universelle qui est qui
nous revient la figure il y a quand même
une arrogance de l'Occident très clair
et bon là malheureusement notre sort est
lié aux États-Unis et très clairement
bascule elle s'est faite lors de la
Seconde Guerre du Golfe à partir du
mensonge de bouche junior et à partir de
ce moment là
ça alimentait des sentiments anti
antioxydants on va dire anti-européen ou
la France malheureusement a été assimilé
alors que justement elle était elle
avait résisté et je pense que ça ça a
complètement alimenté ce sentiment de
haine alors voilà il y a une certaine
arrogance effectivement un discours
universaliste mais qui a servi la cause
coloniale c'est ça le problème c'est ça
qui est discrédité
l'universalisme alors que
l'universalisme à mon sens bien bien
pensé à encore des choses à dire
évidemment
mais lorsqu'il devient l'outil de du
colonialisme évidemment c'est le
discrédite et donc bon c'est son
histoire c'est quand même son arrogance
dont les États-Unis ont les promoteurs
et voilà et donc l'Occident est associé
à ça et je peux le comprendre
après c'est après c'est aussi comment
dire
ce sentiment antioxydantal il est aussi
utiliser par les dirigeants que ce soit
Poutine il a un discours antioxydantal
depuis très longtemps il y a des
certains pays africains ou en Chine
enfin de dire c'est alimenter aussi par
le pouvoir sont instrumentalisés
là-dedans oui il faut toujours trouver
un ennemi et on est un ennemi idéal
quand même alors Mazarine Mitterrand
pinceau je vais vous demander de vous
livrer un petit exercice qui est celui
du questionnaire de Proust que vous
connaissez évidemment si c'était si la
France était un tableau alors
j'hésiterais entre deux types de taffes
de peintres ou de tableaux
je pense à Caillebotte qui pour moi est
complètement associé à Paris aussi parce
que il est assez et que ma mère a
longtemps travaillé au musée et puis
j'ai toujours adoré cette toile Les
Raboteurs là des parquets vous savez et
pour moi je sais pas c'est vraiment
c'est Paris et puis
comme la France n'est pas Paris mais
également
le reste et moi je suis me sens très
ancré dans différents paysages français
et je choisirais sésame parce que je
suis né à Avignon il a peint la sangle
rare
vous allez souvent la Sainte Victoire
alors la victoire moi maintenant même si
j'ai travaillé à Aix j'étais jeune prof
là-bas avec de d'Aix-en-Provence mais en
revanche à Avignon oui très souvent
enfin à côté d'Avignon puisque c'est là
que la France procède de ces territoires
ah oui c'est absolument fondamental
Paris c'est un lieu où les gens se
retrouvent mais avant ne laissez pas à
Paris maintenant nos enfants naissent à
Paris mais moi toute ma famille vient de
province enfin on dit plus province
parce qu'il paraît que c'est pas mais
les territoires mais voilà moi mon
ancrage il est il est très clairement
auvergnat landais
un petit bout quand même en Charente et
puis dans le sud-est près d'Avignon
alors si justement si c'était un paysage
la France
si c'était un paysage donc voilà comme
j'ai un choix immense
l'Auvergne parce que
ma famille je viens de là j'ai passé
toutes mes vacances et puis la chaîne
des puits c'est absolument sublime ça
reste sauvage encore aujourd'hui et
voilà c'est mon paysage aussi d'enfant
quoi d'accord si c'était un écrivain
c'était un écrivain là encore c'est
horrible de répondre ces questions
est-ce que il y a un choix tellement
infini je dirais standard parce que
parce que c'est un des écrivains que
j'affectionne le plus et je sais pas
pour moi il a une plume qui est
française quoi il est il a un génie un
panache c'est à la fois drôle élégant
subtil profond c'est plutôt
le rouge et le noir ou plutôt la
Chartreuse de part
un personnage historique
c'est difficile je pourrais dire mon
père évidemment mais
sauf que c'est pas pour moi un
personnage historique alors je triche ça
l'est aussi mais
je dirais aussi pour ramener un petit
peu de philosophie dans tout ça René
Descartes
qui est un peu
d'abord qui est un philosophe sur lequel
j'ai beaucoup travaillé que j'adore et
puis pour le coup qui est vraiment la
matrice de la pensée française il fait
partie des humanités il fait partie de
l'éducation et donc il y a pas un
écrivain ou un philosophe français qui
ne sait d'abord ressourcer à des cartes
ou qui a commencé par penser par des cas
alors après pour s'en éloigner peut-être
ou pour le contredire ou pour le quitter
mais il fait partie vraiment de lyrique
comme ça la pensée même si même si elle
n'est pas cartésienne merci Mazarine
Mitterrand pinceau merci beaucoup merci
de cette entretien
[Musique]